hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
this is ro and all today we are doing an
unboxing how excited are you about
unboxings are you really excited you got
me into them and I haven't done very
many in my life but I love them I will
say your unboxing of all of your product
line it was incredible oh yes she's
doing it it took tips from the pro over
here and I'm really excited because
today it's unboxing something Star Wars
now you're familiar with these because
you also have one you have the BBA with
the hands like last year I have the
little one the may have been two years
ago oh it had to be two years ago yeah I
think it was a couple years ago this is
when Maddie was a baby oh look at him
he's the size of bb-8 and that was a
really small bb-8
he was like fine with it yeah he was
really chill I'm gonna send you a video
of cookies first interaction she hates
robots
I thought cooking in the other room
that's good because she's not gonna like
we don't happen it I did not want her to
destroy beat you so we're just gonna
take the top off are you ready okay I'm
fining you 300
jiggle-jiggle we that's it really I
should have asked you if you wanted r2d2
are you okay on the dark side oh no I'm
fine on the dark okay I'm gonna match
yours okay Oh mines floating okay okay
only for you we're like synchronized
swimmers more unboxing Kinesis I take it
and he's like oh okay go for it okay
it's this really sling I think it needs
to be turned on for his head
oh it's magnetic so this is great news
because it looks like r2 his head is
also gonna be moving cords all very
important kind of looks like it's just a
USB micro and yours also those USB micro
I don't want to miss anything I'm gonna
be thorough okay okay this is what
that's it so this is the one that looks
like my needs base what's that Oh
oh I so maybe this is like what it's
like it looks like a treadmill so you
can just like work out and roll back and
forth wait
no you can view films with bb9 II by
your side and they make noise they
interact with a movie
what yes so if you're watching the movie
you can have this little guy and he'll
interact we gotta do a marathon night
you have to watch the movie with him so
I think the first step is to make sure
that we have the app downloaded to my
email oh my god it's asking me all these
questions I'm wondering my lips just hit
this one look oh there he is look at
that oh wow it hasn't located a long
range because mine's in the other room
and it can sense it alright you guys so
we have to wait there's a firmware
update so we're just gonna wait we're
just gonna hang out yep his look his
lights are on
oh wait a minute you two oh yeah look at
this you guys look like Justine brought
me the biggest iced coffee you've ever
seen and I loved every minute of it
there was no size specified so I did
just text an iced coffee the time is now
we control them huh whoa girl oh my gosh
arches might pop down what does that
happen
Justine he's looking at me he is looking
[Music]
oh my
oh he is ready to roll
where's god these are so awesome and
cool ooh that I thought it was gonna be
he is adorable it's really cute oh my
gosh aren't you I love you love it's how
I'm sure he's had something to say to
you so this is the controls like this oh
[Music]
there must have been a setting that's
that play dead here's where you drag
around right just to use it and this is
how you drive oh okay but you can drive
around over here sorry about that you
push those that's how you they can talk
to each other or well you can make him
say different things okay let's try one
okay let's do ok Justine I'm gonna drive
this over do you okay I got your water
on my wrong way sorry sorry okay he's a
little tricky the table settings nope
nope yeah nice I'm gonna make You
Justine bla bla convert oh he answers
every time you do it I wonder if he'll
answer back these are so cool and
there's so many different things that
you can do there's like a trace to draw
so you can draw pass around baby there's
this little screen up here vp8 antenna
is broken the little because cookie
chomped on it both of these droids
connected to my phone right now so I've
got r2d2 and bb-8 and you could just
quickly switch through so if you only
have one phone and you can control all
of them to one phone that's pretty cool
oh oh oh he's seen some things you can
be friends it's okay
I'll put this low battery and bb-8 place
into this charger he's still working
though in a way charger I love that they
interact with each other so this is like
control panel but there's all these
other things about all the other things
they can do so this is the one that I
did and he took off Wow this is the one
Justine's talking about if you hit this
button you can draw a path and they'll
follow it so you know what I'm gonna
draw I'm gonna draw a heart
yeah we draw it very small very small
cuz we have one right here so I'm gonna
draw a very small heart there it's a
little boy oh gosh okay well oops
these are definitely something that you
want to be like sitting on the floor for
but for display purposes this is the
best that we can do for you okay okay oh
so Jesse he's still drawing a heart on
the ground he's drawn a heart
no stop I'm so sorry oh no like where's
it where's his head Jesse oh my head oh
my goodness okay so definitely for that
setting might want it yeah I'm so sorry
this is the section where it says tap to
select the movie you want to watch with
your droid we have to do they should do
this says leave the app open even if you
own more than one droid tap the scan
icon to connect multiple droids
plug in the device and start the movie
that would be so cool we could put this
on have all of the droids hanging out
together
I want to film
and they would interact with the film oh
it's so cool well I think that's it
there's so many things that you can do
with this and we just showed you a few
of the demo hello we just showed you a
few demonstrations so maybe we should
have them say bye yeah let's do that
okay I loved it so much make sure you're
going to go check out Roe's channel and
be sure to subscribe if you're not
already and we will see you in the next
videos yeah I think it's a guy again
[Music]
great shot guys